حياتهم مع رفيده ياسين على العربيه
واليوم ارحل مثيره وخطيره للتعرف على عالم
فيه خبايا واسرار
ومفاجات
سنتعرف كيف تحول السحر الاسود الى مذهب
عقائدي
هل هو السحر والشر ام مجرد طقوس
في خبايا غرب افريقيا وفي اجزاء من منطقه
الكاريبي بنتشر مذهب بيدعى البدو او
بالفرنسيه بدو
انتشرت حول المذهب ده قصص واساطير وروايات
لتتعلق بالسحر الاسود والشعوذه وفقا
لمعتقد سائد فان اتباع البعده بيقوم بغرس
دبابيس في دمى بتمثل اعدائهم
وبيحرجوهم على امل ان تصيبوا اللعنه حتى
اصبح مصطلح البدو بيعرف على انه نوع من
انواع السحر الاسود اللي بيقوم اهله
باستخدام الاشباح والجن لخدمه
بحسب معتقدات البدو فالاله يمثل ارواح
الاجداد والاباء اللي ماتوا والارواح ذي
قادره على مساعدتهم او حتى معاقبتهم حسب
تصرفاتهم وبالتالي فان المعتقد ده بيعتبر
دائره مقدسه تربط بين الاحياء وكل طقوسم
الذي مرسوها بترتبط في الاساس على ارضاء
ارواح الموتى لنيل رضاعهم
كثيرا ما تتمثل صوره الاله في معتقد الهدى
في هيئه افعوان ضخم حتى ان البعض ترجمه
كلمه الافعى على انها الافعى الضخمه اللي
بتجمع كل من لديهم ايمان هذا المعتقد
اعتقد الهدى بينتشر بشكل كبير في توغو
وبيعتبر ديانا رسميا في بنين وصل الى
امريكا اللاتينيه قديما عبر السفن
انه في عدد من الالهه قد يصلوا الى 40 الى
او اكثر بس لكل اله مهمه او تخصص محدد وفق
معتقداتهم
يؤمن بانه لكل اله من هؤلاء الالهه
بيختار بنفسه للتواصل مع الاشخاص
المؤمنين ومعروف دهنت البودو انهم رجال
غريبى الاطوار بيدعوا اتقان الطلاسم
وحيازه اسرار النجوم بيقولوا انهم قادرين
على قراءه الكف وقراءه العيون واستشراف او
استشراق المستقبل بالاضافه الى قراءه
الفناجين
واتخذ هؤلاء من عاصمه توغو عاصمه عالميه
للشعوذه اصبحت ملتقى لكل المؤمنين
بمعتقد البذور هذه المجموعه اسست اكبر سوق
مخصص لمواد السحر والعلاجات الشعبيه ذو
اكثر من قرن ونصف من الزمن وحين كان
المكان ده داخل حدود مملكه دهومي اللي هي
بتعتبر بنين حاليا هذا السوق الذي يجمع كل
متعلقات السحر الاسود يسمى السوق
او سوق الشعوذه او العلاجات الشعبيه زي ما
هما بيحبوا تسميته
في السوق الغريب والمريب ده قد تجد مسحوق
حرباء او جمجمه فرس او حتى كف غوريلا
وربما يكون هناك ضرس التمساح او حتى قدم
فيل او ريشه من غراب او راس ثور او قرن او
شعر لاي حيوان او حتى كبرى مجففه او فرو
دب وغيره من اطراف مختلفه الحيوانات ليه
انهم بيستخدم هذه الاجزاء من الحيوانات في
ممارسه طقوس الخاصه بالسحر الاسود
والشعوده
الاشياء دي بتعتبر عند الفودو هي العلاج
الفعلي لما يصيب الناس من امراض ومشكلات
اجتماعيه وماليه او حتى تحديات سياسيه زي
ما هما بيعتقدوا وبيروا انه معتقدم
وممارسه طقوس قد تكون حل لاي مشكله متعلقه
بالانسان
وتقديم القرابين للارواح دي بيعتبر طقس
خاص بتختلف تفاصيله بين منطقه واخرى لكن
اللي بيجمع بيننا في كل الاحوال الغناء
والرقص وقرع الطبول وقراءه تمتمات او
كلمات بدون غير مفهومه الا لاصحاب من
المشعودين
اتباع الهدوء بيدعوا انهم قادرين على
استحضار الارواح بدقوس معينه وانهم
بامكانهم التكلم مع الارواح بشكل مباشر
اعتقاداتهم او ادعاءاتم
بيعتقد بعض المؤرخين انه المعتقده وجد في
افريقيا قبل اكثر من 10000 سنه بس بيميل
البعض الاخر الى الاعتقاد بانه معتقد
البودو ونشا بعد الاحتلال الاوروبي
لافريقيا وعند انتشار تجاره العبيد لانه
في الوقت اذا كان الاوروبيون بيحاولوا
تمزيق المعتقدات الدينيه لدى الافارقه
لتحويل الى جماعات يسهل السيطره عليها
ودهبي حسب المؤرخين والباحثين اللي جعل
الطوائف المختلفه من الافارقه بيتحدوا
ويمزج شعائر الدينيه مع بعضهم
ويمكن منهم انهم يكونوا مجموعات قادره على
المقاومه حسب هذه المقوله
فقط سائل بيقول انه البدو يمكن ان يغرسوا
دبابيس في الدمى
ليقضوا على اعدائهم وانهم بهذه الطريقه
بامكانهم الحفاظ على معتقدم من اي شرور
خارجيه او من اي محاولات لتشتيتهم او
تقسيمهم او للقضاء على هذا العالم وبيقال
حسب ما يروي البعض ان هم بيهددوا انه
بامكانهم تحويل الناس الى زومبي
البودو بيعتبر من اشهر المعتقدات المتعلقه
بالسحر الاسود
يعتقد الباحثين انه هذا المذهب وجد في
افريقيا حتى منذ التاريخ الانساني ليس فقط
من عشره الاف سنه والكلمه بحد ذات مشتقه
من كلمه بتعني الروح في اللغه الفرنسيه
وانتشر المعتقد لنشا في الكاريبي سريعا
حتى شمل عده دول افريقيه وتساهم في
انتشاره حتى اصبح عندما مجموعات في الدول
المتعدده بيتواصلوا مع بعضهم البعض على
طريقتهم الخاصه
وبيتجمعوا في توغو سنويا
للاحتفال وممارسه القسم عقيده البدو انه
الاله في معتقداتهم بيمثل ارواح والارواح
دي بتتحكم في مصائب وبتحكم تصرفاتهم
معتقد موجود وبيؤمن بعض الناس قبائل بتعيش
على السحر الاسود بيقال انها بتلعب مع
الشياطين وتقدم القرابين وتمارس طقوس
السحر منذ قرن وحاليا يقام مهرجان سنوي في
دوله بنين لممارسه هذه الطقوس من خلال
فعاليه ضخمه جدا بيحضاره الالاف من
اتباعها ومشعوذيها وايضا بيحضر اليها ناس
من بلدان مختلفه بينهما الفضول الراغب في
التعرف على خبايا هذا العالم واسراره
وبينهم من يؤمن بهذه المعتقدات وبغض النظر
عن انه العالم دمه خفيف وغامض وفيه اساطير
وحكايات مختلفه
بيبقى موجود ومهم لاتباعه اللي عايشين منه
والمتمسكين جدا بممارسه طقوسم وغير حريصين
على اي تدخ تزعزع معتقداتهم اللي هم سعداء
بممارسته في اماكنهم دون ازعاج الاخرين
ببساطه لان هذه هي حياتهم
[موسيقى]